Drew ski is launching his own sports
agency we know and love drewski First
comedy skits but apparently he's taking
this very seriously it's called for
lifer sports agency and he already has
an NFL prospect and four-star recruit
out of Florida as his first client this
launch might seem random but he's
actually had his hand in the industry
for a minute he's a co-owner of a
franchise in the fan controlled Football
League Andrews he also starred in an NBA
Google commercial last year to tease the
new season drewski says launching his
for life or sports agency lets him
combine his two passions sports and
entertainment and he wants to provide
athletes with resources support and
marketing on and off the field